well I think this administration has has
has really fundamentally back up very
own syllabus this administration has
been both a political and the moral
failure and America's role in the world
has been just shattered just just
squandered we've lost the moral high
ground in in the world at at home people
have lost their confidence in in their
society their government and not just
people in New Orleans but across the
country but I think that can be changed
I think new leadership can fix that but
you know what whoever might win the next
election I out to audiences whoever
you're and the people running for are
ready for all of us some of them are
good friends of mine so I like some of
them and I I wish them success but who
if your favorite candidate wins they
will not be able to change the really
big issues without social movements
outside of politics that change politics
when politics is broken and fails to
address the really big issues social
movements rise up to change politics and
the best social movements often have
spiritual foundations it's like
mountains take the pandemic of hiv/aids
or global poverty three billion of God's
children half of us live on less than
two dollars a day thirty thousand kids
die today and will tomorrow and the next
day because of lack of clean drinking
water and diseases my four-year-old
eight-year-old none of their friends
will die of and no food that is with
Bono called stupid poverty it's utterly
preventable that's a mountain Darfur you
know we keep explaining why we can't
stop Darfur but it go who goes on
climate change global warming's are like
mountains and they're huge and my Bible
says if you have faith the size of a
mustard seed it can move a mountain I
think we're not going to get to so
so justice without a revival of faith
and I mean not just dogmatic religion
I'm talking about the kind of
transformation personal and social trust
which that comes from True Religion real
spirituality so I think the future
religion has been kind of a problem
parochial narrow not helpful partisan
but it may be in the future a big part
of our solutions as we break the kind of
old religion the people of God shouldn't
be in any party's political pocket or
candidates but should evaluate politics
by our moral compass so I want to build
social movements outside of politics
that really can transform politics and
address the biggest issues the big
issues and there are big ones out there
they're like these mountains that have
to be moved and I you know like faith to
move them